einschläge im sekundentakt an at&t
angriff mitten in einem wohngebiet in hf
im osten der ukraine
mehrere dutzend tote und verletzte
zivilisten soll es gegeben haben und
auch nahe der hauptstadt kiew gibt es
weiterhin gefechte ein öl depot soll
explodiert seien ursache vermutlich eine
russische rakete bilder die sich nicht
verlässlich bestätigen lassen
währenddessen kamen am mittag russische
und ukrainische unterhändler nahe der
bälle russischen grenze zu gesprächen
zusammen
guten abend willkommen zum zdf spezial
nach wie vor gibt es heftige kämpfe vor
allem um kiew und die zweitgrößte
ukrainische stadt hat putin hat außerdem
angeordnet die atomstreitkräfte in
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen
eine drohgebärde die wohl vor allem
verunsichern und beunruhigen soll zu den
sogenannten friedensgesprächen hat die
russische seite politiker aus der
zweiten reihe entsandt das sagt schon
viel aus über die ernsthaftigkeit dieser
gespräche ein schnelles ende des krieges
ist jedenfalls nicht in sicht achim
flora fast den tag zusammen
russische panzer auf dem vormarsch die
offensive am fünften tag des krieges
geht weiter auf ukrainischem boden in
nicolai wka in der don jetzt region
werden russische fahnen für die kamera
gehisst russland lässt erfolge vermelden
putins armee sprecher erklärt über 1000
ziele der ukrainischen militär
infrastruktur seien zerstört die
lufthoheit gesichert die städte brillanz
genero dahl eingenommen außerdem die
atomanlage in sapporo jap was davon
stimmt schwer nachzuprüfen
die ukrainische seite schickt diese
drohnen bilder um die welt sie sollen
die zerstörung eines russischen
raketenwerfer zeigen und dass sich die
angegriffenen erfolgreich wehren bisher
wohl erfolgreicher als viele
militärexperten glaubten bei kiew und
hart treffen die russischen kräfte auf
erbitterten widerstand im südosten und
osten kommen sie wohl schneller voran
immer mehr ukrainische reservisten
werden an die waffe gerufen und sie
kommen irland gegen einen scheinbar
übermächtigen feind zu verteidigen
wir verteidigen unser zuhause deswegen
werden diese einfachen jungs jetzt
eingezogen es sind große patrioten sie
wissen was zu tun ist und gegen den
feind stoppen
ihr präsident heute wendet er sich auch
an die russischen soldaten auf russisch
werft eure waffen weg cent geht glaubt
nicht euren kommandeuren glaubt nicht
der propaganda rettet einfach euer leben
und geht
wir haben sie nicht in unser dorf
gelassen hört man auf diesem handy video
und tatsächlich scheint ist dass einige
kilometer nordöstlich von kiew die
bewohner von corio kipka die russischen
panzer stoppen konnten ohne waffen nur
mit verzweifeltem mut
nicht weit entfernt den sheriff dicke
rauchschwaden über der 300.000 einwohner
stadt eine rakete schlug in ein
einkaufszentrum ein die echtheit dieser
bilder auch hier schwer zu überprüfen
rund um mario pohl toben ebenfalls
heftige kämpfe die einwohner der
hafenstadt am schwarzen meer bereiten
sich auf die nächste angriffswelle vor
sie suchen schutz so gut es geht vor
akten und granaten
es gibt hoffnung mit den
friedensverhandlungen denn jeder will
doch frieden wir hoffen auf ein ergebnis
damit nicht noch mehr zivilisten getötet
werden
hoffnung auf frieden sehr viel mehr
bleibt in diesen tagen nicht den
menschen in mariupol und überall sonst
in der ukraine
in münchen begrüße ich den ehemaligen
general und militärberater von kanzlerin
merkel erich fahrt guten abend genau der
vorlauf wie stellt sich denn die
situation im kriegsgebiet im moment da
aus ihrer sicht na ja wir haben den
fünften kriegstag und der russische
vormarsch der in den ersten tagen sehr
flott vonstatten ging scheint sich
verlangsamt zu haben besonders im raum
charkow und auch in kiew hier ist das
risiko sehr groß dass man sich in orts-
und häuserkampf
verzahnt mit dem tapferen ukrainischen
verteidigern und das könnte zum problem
werden
für putins truppen in mario pohl wird
auch gekämpft hier versuchen die russen
die landverbindung zwischen der krim und
auch dem donkers zu schließen da sind
sie relativ erfolgreich aber mario pohl
ist eben auch hart umkämpft und man muss
wirklich sagen die ukraine schon
verteidiger machen ihre sache wirklich
sehr gut die kampfmoral ist ja hoch
obwohl die ukrainischen streitkräfte
materiell eben stark unterlegen sind
gegenüber den russischen wie schätzen
sie denn die atomare bedrohung ein wieso
hat putin diese verbale eskalation ist
es ja mal zumindest nötig
naja ich glaube er hat sie nötig weil er
massiv unter druck steht dass
sanktionspaket
ist beträchtlich seine oligarchen
freunde das ist ja jetzt auch öffentlich
geworden fangen an sich zu distanzieren
er braucht letztlich erfolge und das ist
auch natürlich auch ein innenpolitisches
problem für die russen mit dem
sogenannten bruder volk ukraine im krieg
zu sehen zu stehen also dass kann er
nicht so lange machen deswegen bringt er
die nuklearwaffen ins spiel
nuklearwaffen spielen natürlich im
hintergrund an ist jeden konventionellen
konfliktes seit 45 eine rolle also seit
der kuba-krise wir haben das auch im
jom-kippur-krieg es gibt unzählige
beispiele
aber das sind sie jetzt so offen
adressiert sie werden ihnen nicht helfen
in der ukraine sie können nicht die
ukraine besetzen und sie sicher nicht
sagen militärischen erfolg dort was
würde es denn ändern sollte russland
tatsächlich atomwaffen in belarus
stationieren
ja man muss schauen was die russen jetzt
überhaupt machen im zuge der nato
ostgrenze die nato überlegt ja schon wie
sie sich dort besser aufstellt die
personellen materiellen verstärkungen
laufen und wir müssen natürlich
überlegen ob wir die gründungsakte nato
russland grund akte ob das alles so
bleibt ob wir tatsächlich auf dauer nur
rotierend und nicht ständig dort
stationieren ob wir auch substanzielle
kampftruppen an die ost ganze verlegen
müssen und wenn putin mit solchen dingen
kommt und mit solchen drohungen wird man
von seiten des westens auf reagieren
müssen da bin ich mir sicher und dann
ist alles anders ein blick noch auf die
bundeswehr bedingt einsatzbereit lautet
da der traurige befund jetzt sollen 100
100 milliarden euro die bundeswehr
stärken wie lange wird es dauern bis das
wirkung zeigt
das wird tatsächlich einige jahre dauern
der zustand der bundeswehr ist nicht nur
bedingte einsatzbereitschaft sondern
kann auch sagen sie sind für die landes-
und bündnisverteidigung nicht
einsatzbereit und wir werden jahre
brauchen um die bundeswehr hochzufahren
dieses milliarden paket ist notwendig
aber man muss es auch politisch
kontrollieren damit es nicht versickert
letztlich und im gießkannenprinzip
verteilt wird in der bundeswehr sondern
man muss wirklich aus dem kanzleramt
heraus festlegen was wir wollen welche
stärke welche kräfte welche
waffensysteme was vorrangig ist das her
zum beispiel müssen wir dringend
hochfahren auf drei divisionen wir
brauchen die f35 für die nukleare
teilhabe da geht kein weg dran vorbei
aber das musste letztlich definiert
werden im kanzleramt und das muss von
dort aus gesteuert wird vielen dank nach
münchen wer ich war vielen dank herr
vorn auf
unsere reporterin katrin eigendorf ist
mit ihrem team im westen der ukraine
gute namen kathrin was haben sie denn
heute dort gesehen und erlebt
ja wir mussten heute die stadt in der
wir uns die letzten tage aufgehalten
haben verlassen weil sich dort im
prinzip eine brenzliche situation
ergeben hat die leute werden dort sehr
nervös gucken auf alle fremden und wir
wurden gestern mit unserem team von im
prinzip einer selbsternannten bürgerwehr
umzingelt die haben uns am drehen
gehindert und wir haben beschlossen den
ort zu wechseln und sind 120 kilometer
entfernt gefahren auf dem weg durchs
land muss man sagen die ukraine haben
inzwischen überall so genannte
checkpoints eingerichtet man kann sich
teilweise so vor wie in den jahren
2014 2015 im osten der ukraine
also das land ist wirklich breitflächig
im krieg und alle leute bereiten sich im
prinzip darauf vor auch hier russische
bodentruppen
aufzuhalten sind misstrauisch inzwischen
gegen jeden fremden und auch gegenüber
journalisten die stimmung ist doch schon
sehr angespannt wie schätzen sie dann
ihre eigene sicherheitslage jetzt ein
wird dort wo sie sind weniger heftig
gekämpft
die kämpfe konzentrieren sich im moment
ganz besonders auf hf im osten der
ukraine die zweitgrößte stadt mario pohl
und natürlich kiew wir sind hier noch
relativ sicher sofern man das sagen kann
aber im prinzip ist die gesamte ukraine
natürlich für putin kriegsgebiet das
heißt wir müssen auch hier damit rechnen
dass hier möglicherweise angriffe
stattfinden es gibt auch immer wieder
alarm dass man in den bunker gehen muss
also die bevölkerung ist auch hier dazu
aufgerufen wenn es an fliegeralarm gibt
sich in ihren kellern zurückzuziehen
einfach aus sicherheitsgründen man geht
auch davon aus dass russland hier
mittlerweile mit sogenannten saboteuren
im land unterwegs ist also insgesamt
doch eine sehr misstrauisch und
angespannte stimmung aber natürlich ist
die situation hier noch nicht so schlimm
wie zum beispiel nach es ja ganz ganz
schlimme an heute gegeben hatten
hunderttausende menschen sind ja auf der
flucht mittlerweile nur raus aus den
städten oder oder wollen die meisten
über die grenze in die nachbarländer
also vor allem wollen die leute aus den
städten raus man rechnet damit dass sich
wahrscheinlich fünf millionen ukrainer
in den in der zukunft auf die flucht
machen werden weil man ja auch damit
rechnen muss dass dieser krieg jetzt
erheblich brutaler geführt wird putin
wird das deutet sich an und davon gehen
auch alle experten aus mehr noch gegen
zivilisten vorgehen es ist ja jetzt
schon so dass krankenhäuser getroffen
werden dass kindergärten getroffen
wurden und die menschen rechnen einfach
damit dass das hier ein sehr erbitterter
krieg wird und vor allem familien mit
kindern versuchen natürlich auch jetzt
das land noch zu verlassen männer im
alter von 18 bis 60 jahren können das ja
gar nicht die müssen ja hier bleiben die
ukraine stellt sich insgesamt hier auf
einen längeren krieg die menschen haben
im moment relativ wenig hoffnung in
friedensverhandlungen
vielen dank für diese schilderungen
katrin eigendorf
das un flüchtlingshilfswerk hat heute
von 500.000 menschen gesprochen die in
folge der russischen invasion aus dem
land geflüchtet sind wie sie aufgenommen
und versorgt werden zeigt uns britta
hilpert
am grenzübergang wie in den levels care
sieht man jeden tag solche szenen und
immer sind sie einzigartig wiedersehen
sicherheit erleichterung tanja nastia
warten noch auf verwandte aus polen 24
stunden unterwegs sind sie aus einem
keyboard vor ort neun stunden davon
staus wir haben unterwegs ukrainische
tanker und schweres gerät gesehen und
ihr mann frage ich er blieb dort sagt
sie voller sorge es wirkt heute
organisierte an der slowakisch
ukrainischen grenze beheizte zelte hat
man aufgebaut wo sie bereitgestellt für
transporte gen westen oder in
auffanglager
das größte ist 40 kilometer entfernt in
humane
500 menschen kommen hier unter es ist
halb voll aber es wird bald erweitert
man erwartet noch viel mehr oxana zeigt
uns hier zählt es sei ganz okay sagt sie
warm und trocken der kleinste ecke drei
wochen alt fühlt sich sichtlich wohl
ihre töchter sind hier aber die männer
sind in der ukraine geblieben kämpfen
das mitgefühl mit solchen schicksalen
ist an der grenze gross schon vor tagen
ist marian technik mit freunden
hergekommen um lebensmittel zu verteilen
unterkünfte zu vermitteln er beobachtet
dass verwandte nicht mehr so häufig
bereit stehen um geflüchtete abzuholen
es werden immer mehr busse und shuttles
genutzt man kann sehen dass die
flüchtenden jetzt keine enge beziehung
in der reha brauchen unsere
unterstützung besonders in den nächsten
tagen
denn sie werden weiter kommen über die
grenze in die slowakei auf der suche
nach sicherheit so lange die kämpfe in
der ukraine dauern
und in polen begrüße ich jetzt chris
melzer vom flüchtlingshilfswerk un hcr
guten abend guten abend sagt beginn des
russischen einmarsches am donnerstag
sind schon 500.000 menschen aus der
ukraine in nachbarländer geflohen sie
sind schon ein paar tage und nacht
unterwegs da an der grenze wie es die
situation dort
ja sie hat nichts von der von der
schwere verloren diese zahl von 500.000
ist von heute morgen mittlerweile sind
es wahrscheinlich viel mehr
wahrscheinlich haben wir sogar schon die
600.000 passiert und die menschen kommen
immer noch wir haben mit dutzenden von
menschen hier an der polnischen grenze
übergangsstellen gesprochen und das ist
im grunde immer die gleiche geschichte
die wir hören die menschen sind sind
ängstlich sind beunruhigt sind auf der
anderen seite erleichtert das sind jetzt
in sicherheit sind aber das schlimmste
für diese menschen ist eigentlich dass
sie immer noch wissen dass die die
verwandten oftmals die männer und väter
eben noch immer rheine sind wie hat sich
dann die lage in den letzten tagen und
stunden verändert kommen jetzt immer
mehr menschen
das hat sich eigentlich nicht großartig
geändert die situation die die ist immer
noch gleich gleich schwer die situation
gleich bedenklich ist auch nach wie vor
so dass wir gewaltige rückstaus haben an
den grenzübergangsstellen und die
menschen die dann hier ankommen sie
sind seit tagen unterwegs sind
durchgefroren wir haben hier
temperaturen von nachts minus 5 -6 grad
es hat heute wieder mal geschneit die
menschen haben nichts warmes zu essen
gehabt und er sind eben fast
ausschließlich frauen und kinder und
ganz oft merken wir eben oder sehen wir
frauen die die babys auf dem arm haben
wo man sich wirklich wundert sie haben
diese leute eigentlich geschafft ja da
würde ich gern noch mal nachfragen wie
werden denn die menschen in polen
aufgenommen gibt's zeltlager reicht der
platz
also die regierung hat hierfür für
aufnahmeeinrichtung gesorgt das sind
also auch so turnhallen schulen und
ähnliches die hergerichtet wurden es ist
aber auch unglaublich wie solidarisch
die polen hier sind direkt an der grenze
stehen stehen menschen die die verteilen
telefonkarten die verteilen decken und
schlafsäcke die stehen dort mit
pappschildern auf denen steht ukraine
auf ukrainisch wo wollen sie hin nicht
phase dahin nach warschau oder oder nach
breslau und ich habe auch mit einer
familie gesprochen mit ihrem kleinen
sohn
entschuldigt und wetter schon wieder
emotionale willst du einfach so
faszinierend dass diese familie gesagt
hat wir haben überlegt wie würde es uns
gehen und dann haben wir ein paar
schlafsäcke decken und als wir unserem
sohn er wacht erklärt haben was da
passiert da hat er nicht sein lieblings
aber es ein zweites spielzeug dann doch
geholt und gespendet wer schöne
geschichte wie kann denn das un hcr den
menschen dort sehr konkret jetzt helfen
also in polen sind wir vor allen dingen
beratend und steuern tätig denn es ist
die aufgabe der natürlich der der
polnischen regierung diesen flüchtlingen
zu helfen wir sind für die für die
krisensituation wird nicht da und
deshalb sind wir in der ukraine wir
haben etwa 120 kollegen die noch da sind
und wir wollen auch nicht gehen und die
begonnen haben dinge zu verteilen wir
nennen das skore lief weiter also
schlafsäcke schlafmatten decken was warm
hält kanister monats eg frauen windeln
zum beispiel aber das machen unsere
kollegen dort natürlich auch unter
extrem schwierigen bedingungen
vielen dank für das gespräch
und wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine
das ist de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
alle infos auch unter spenden zdf.de
oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
wie reagiert die welt auf russlands
angriffskrieg in new york ist am
nachmittag die vollversammlung der
vereinten nationen zu einer
dringlichkeitssitzung zusammengekommen
wie isoliert ist moskau bei den 193
mitgliedsländern sonja berger auf
eine sondersitzung der
un-vollversammlung ist äußerst selten in
der geschichte der vereinten nationen
gab es bisher nur zehn mal eine solche
sitzung der un sicherheitsrat kann die
sondersitzung der vollversammlung
einberufen wenn er selbst nicht mehr
handlungsfähig ist zum beispiel weil
seine aufgaben von einer an einem krieg
beteiligten partei blockiert werden so
wie jetzt von russland in der
vollversammlung gibt es kein vetorecht
bei resolutionen eine mehrheit der
stimmen genügt die resolution die hier
beschlossen werden sind zwar nicht
bindend von ihm geht aber eine hohe
politische bedeutung aus das ziel
diesmal farbe bekennen zur un charta die
einen völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
verbietet und russland zu isolieren und
all diejenigen unter druck zu setzen die
sich bisher bei der verurteilung der
russischen offensive in der ukraine
zurückgehalten haben
wir sind sehr besorgt über die sich
schnell verändernde lage und die
militäraktion in der ukraine wie ich
schon zuvor betont habe die offensive
der russischen föderation verletzt die
territoriale integrität und souveränität
der ukraine und ist unvereinbar mit der
charta der vereinten nationen
und in new york ist unser korrespondent
johannes hano guten abend johannes was
kann denn so eine dringlichkeitssitzung
überhaupt bewirken
dass überhaupt einberufen worden ist
zeigt dass es größere probleme gibt
überhaupt hier eine eine lösung zu
finden in dem ganzen konflikt den
sicherheitsrat konnte sich ja nicht
einigen was am veto russlands
gescheitert ist den angriffskrieg zu
verurteilen was jetzt gewollt ist man
will dass sich diese gesamte welt mit
diesem thema beschäftigt und man hofft
auf eine größtmögliche zustimmung zu
einer resolution die diesen
angriffskrieg verurteilt um russland
ganz klar zu zeigen du stehst hier
alleine und es geht um einen zweiten
punkt es geht auch darum der welt dass
sich die welt selbst versichert dass man
noch zu der charta der vereinten
nationen steht die völkerrechtswidrige
angriffskriege ächtet und das den krieg
als mittel der politik nicht mehr hier
in die politischen alltagsgeschäft
einbezogen werden kann dann versucht
sich die vereinten nationen versuchen
sich durch eine solche sitzung gerade
selbst zu versichern und der druck ist
enorm groß auch wenn das kein ort für
konkrete beschlüsse ist das ein großer
teil der weltgemeinschaft russland als
aggressor benennt und verurteilt ist
auch mittelfristig ein problem für
moskau oder
absolut also was wir hier in den reden
bisher gesehen haben ist die leute alle
die hier gesprochen haben eigentlich
quer über alle kontinente sind massiv
geschockt von der russischen drogen
möglicherweise auch die atomstreitkräfte
einzusetzen das hat hier wirklich alle
sehr geschockt und das führt dazu dass
russland tatsächlich mehr und mehr
isoliert wird es gibt also keine echten
freunde mehr hinter russland im moment
ist wir müssen auch davon ausgehen dass
eine resolution verabschiedet wird und
ich glaube auch in einer sehr großen
mehrheit hier in den vereinten nationen
ja das würde ich wirklich gerne noch mal
nachfragen wer unterstützt denn
eigentlich putin noch international
also den krieg glaube ich so an nach
allem was wir bisher gehört haben das
hat bisher noch ein drittel der
mitgliedsstaaten gesprochen aber nach
allem was wir hören wird der krieg
eigentlich von keinem land wirklich
unterstützt also da steht putin völlig
allein es gibt aber einen kleinen
unterschied china und auch indien haben
sich in resolution enthalten und dort
gibt es mehr strategische interessen vor
allen dingen auf chinas seite jena sagt
die ganze zeit auch heute wieder hier in
den vereinten nationen man müsse
russland auch verstehen es braucht
regionale sicherheit vor ort die rechte
von außen sollen sich raushalten gemeint
sind natürlich die amerikaner und da hat
man den hintergedanken dass man wenn
russland das problem in europa ist
möglicherweise man selbst das problem
auch in asien lösen kann wo man sich
selber dahin stellt und die rolle
amerikas einnehmen möchte nämlich noch
vormacht in der region also es gibt
keine echten verbündeten muss man sagen
aber es gibt durchaus länder die ein
strategisches interesse haben den
konflikt in einer art und weise zu lösen
der ihnen selbst zu teil wird vielen
dank für diese einschätzungen nach new
york
die beziehungen zwischen russland und
deutschland waren auch in jüngster zeit
nicht immer einfach der krieg gegen die
ukraine wird alle bemühungen um jahre
zurückwerfen jetzt sollen sanktionspaket
russland möglichst schwächen deutschland
großbritannien usa kanada japan die
schweiz die liste der länder die
sanktionen verhängen wird jeden tag
länger die auswirkungen werden alle
treffen nicht nur russland wie bereiten
sich deutsche unternehmen darauf vor
claudia krafczyck berichtet
für krebs fabrikant hermann bühlbecker
sind wandel durch handel keine leeren
worte gorbatschow hat ihn persönlich
empfangen und putin lernte er vor zwei
jahren mit einer wirtschaftsdelegation
in moskau seine lambertz gruppe gehört
zum ost ausschuss der deutschen
wirtschaft der seit anfang der 50er
jahre für den abbau von handelsschranken
kämpft wir haben überlegt wie können wir
die beziehungen der beiden länder
intensivieren und es ist ja auch oft so
je intensiver die wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen sind und so weniger können
sich beide seiten im krieg vorstellen
tatsächlich liefen die geschäfte
zwischen deutschland und russland gerade
wieder gut im vergangenen jahr brachten
es ex und importe auf knapp 60
milliarden euro ein plus von rund 34
prozent
jetzt könnte der krieg zur vollbremsung
führen wir sind absolut sicher dass es
natürlich gravierende auswirkung auf
deutsche unternehmen haben wird allein
wenn man sich die sanktionen den
finanzsektor ansieht wir haben sorge vor
eventuellen russischen gegen sanktionen
es ist da war heute zu früh wirklich
ganz solide zu kalkulieren was dass wir
konkrete auswirkungen haben wird die
sanktionen gegen russland sollen auf
drei ebenen wirken es werden konten
gesperrt das zahlungssystem swift
blockiert und transaktionen mit der
zentralbank verboten vor allem hightech
waren fallen unter das exportverbot und
es wird einreisebeschränkungen geben das
ziel für russland von den finanzströmen
abkoppeln und die wirtschaft lahmlegen
doch putin hat rücklagen geschätzt 560
milliarden euro
die zentralbank hat erhebliche
vermögenswerte im ausland liegen und
wenn die eingefroren werden können sie
eben nicht dazu verwendet werden die
kugel zu stützen also nach den
schätzungen die ich gesehen habe ist
ungefähr die hälfte tatsächlich in
international also ungefähr 40 prozent
bei den westlichen verbündeten
14 prozent wohl in china er hat
allerdings auch massive gold reserven
aufgebaut hier ist die rede von 140
milliarden nur die muss er natürlich
auch erst mal verkaufen können
schon einmal wurden gegen russland
sanktionen verhängt 2014 nach der krim
annexion die folgen hat der strick moden
hersteller aus chemnitz bitter erleben
müssen verluste in millionenhöhe und die
kündigung von mitarbeitern
denn damals brachen zwei drittel seines
russland umsatzes weg es war ja nicht
nur decken und fliegt selbst und damit
eben auch die vorsicht der andere
partner sondern das war ja auch die die
die die wechselkurse unser unsere waren
haben sich ja von heute auf morgen
drastisch verteuert in russland
beispielsweise dadurch dass der rubel
kurs sehr stark nachgegeben hatte worauf
wir uns einstellen mussten wo wir ihm
auch sehr sehr viel geld verloren haben
diesmal hat er vorgesorgt der
umsatzanteil mit russland beträgt nur
noch 4,5 prozent und waren gibt es nur
noch gegen vorkasse
in berlin begrüße ich den
wirtschaftswissenschaftler und russland
experten alexander liebmann guten abend
guten abend wie bewerten sie die bis
jetzt bekannten sanktionen für russland
aber auch für deutschlands wirtschaft
die sanktionen haben auf jeden fall eine
sehr starke wirkung auf der russische
wirtschaft was zum teil daran liegt dass
die deutlich schärfer sind als ich
selbst noch vor ein paar tagen vermuten
würde man muss aber auch zugeben dass
die sanktionen schon jetzt die deutsche
wirtschaft beeinflussen etwa indem dass
die energiepreise steigen und man muss
damit rechnen dass die wirkung über die
zeit stärker wird das auch die deutsche
wirtschaft darunter leiden würden
russische banken werden jetzt zum teil
von den internationalen finanzmärkten
ausgeschlossen
sie sollen in der eu kein geld mehr
leihen und verleihen dürfen ist das aus
ihrer sicht ein wirksames instrument ist
ein wirksames instrument das würde den
zugang der russischen banken zu
liquidität einschränken aber jetzt geht
es eigentlich um viel schärfere
sanktionen schrift sanktionen und
sanktionen gegen die russische
zentralbank die die russischen banken
eine noch viel schlimmere lage versetzen
der wert des rubels ist ja geradezu
abgestürzt was bedeutet das für russland
naja der absturz des wertes der
nationalen währung hat eigentlich eine
doppelte bedeutung einerseits geht es
darum dass die importe deutlich teurer
werden sie haben das jetzt gerade
gezeigt jetzt ist es
russinnen und russen deutlich teurer
zugang zu im ausland produzierten gütern
und dienstleistungen zu bekommen und was
außerdem wichtig ist wert der des rubels
hat eine symbolische bedeutung ein
symbol der stabilität der wirtschaft das
ist nach dem gestrigen tag nicht mehr
gegeben die eu mitgliedstaaten haben
sich auf exportkontrollen für
hightech-produkte geeinigt sie sollen es
den russischen schlüsselindustrien
erschweren sich weiterzuentwickeln
kann das gelingen es wird sehr
wahrscheinlich gelingen weil die
russische wirtschaft trotz der
bemühungen der import substitution der
letzten jahre nach wie vor gerade im
technologiebereich sehr stark vom westen
abhängig ist eine wichtige rolle wird
aber dabei china spielen falls man
zugang zu high tech gütern zumindest zum
teil über china bekommen kann wird der
schlag auf die russische wirtschaft
abgeschwächt
russland wird ja auch von banken
kommunikationsnetzwerk schrift sie haben
deutschland erwähnt abgeschnitten was
bedeutet das für russland das hat sehr
starke auswirkungen vor allem auf den
internationalen handel es wird es für
die russischen banken deutlich
schwieriger die transaktionen
abzuwickeln auf jeden fall für die
banken die jetzt von swift abgekoppelt
wurden es sind nicht alle banken und auf
diese weise kann es tatsächlich zu
geschäften kommen die zumindest
vorübergehend gar nicht stattfinden
können also das sind schon sehr sehr
starke maßnahmen ja vielen dank für das
gespräch alexander liebmann vielen dank
es ist der fünfte tag des krieges ein
ende der kampfhandlungen ist nicht in
sicht ein stabiler frieden erst recht
nicht die entwicklungen dieses tages
haben mario savvis und bettler störer
für sie nachgezeichnet
wir werden uns nicht ergeben wir lassen
uns nicht kopieren nicht von putin aus
jedem fenster wird hier eine waffe
herausschauen
heute vormittag in die pro
entschlossenheit in der viertgrößten
stadt der ukraine im osten des landes
mit unmengen an flaschen rücken sie an
um daraus molotow cocktails zu bauen
brand flaschen als waffen für den fall
dass russische panzer und soldaten bis
in die stadt vordringen sollten
ich bin eigentlich zahnarzt und hätte
niemals gedacht dass es dazu kommt aber
so ist das jetzt eben
und an anderer stelle der millionenstadt
mikro hier bringen die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner lebensmittel getränke und alles
sonstige heran von dem sie meinen dass
es die freiwilligen an der front
gebrauchen könnten
heute haben wir wasser und lebensmittel
für die freiwilligen eingekauft und
gestern auch kleidung und unterwäsche
für aufbruch und ankommen stehen
bahnhöfe in normalen zeiten
doch hier in kiew sind diese zeiten
gerade vorbei der hauptbahnhof heute
morgen auch am fünften tag der
russischen invasion draußen leere
bahnsteige und drinnen ein zufluchtsort
für all jene die durch den krieg und die
nächtliche ausgangssperre zum bleiben
gezwungen sind
bahnhof sind hier gerade nicht so viele
menschen
wegen der strikten ausgangssperre die
bis in den morgen
heute endet sie um 8 uhr
als der tag dann beginnt in kiew und die
ausgangssperre vorbei ist bleiben die
straßen doch zumeist menschenleer denn
auch in der nacht war wieder das
donnergrollen von explosionen und
schüsse zu hören von einer weiteren
höllischen nacht sprach kiews
bürgermeister vitali klitschko heute
vereinte durchhaltewillen mit einem
eindringlichen appell um weitere hilfe
unsere frauen kinder ältere menschen
gehen durch die hölle wir brauchen jetzt
ihre hilfe dringend hilfe um unsere
bürger zu verteidigen um zu uns zu
beschützen beschützen und zu beleben
bitte spenden auf das konto der
ukrainischen nationalbank was ihr könnt
spendet für das überleben spendet für
das frieden frieden in europa aber
frieden liegt wohl noch in einiger ferne
und so verteilt man den tief rund 25.000
gewehre nicht an soldaten sondern an
künstler rechtsanwälte sportler
jeder der das land verteidigen kann muss
zu den waffen greifen ich bin froh dass
es unseren abgeordneten gelungen ist das
kriegsrecht zu verhängen danach stellten
sie sich gemeinsam für waffen auf soweit
ich weiß haben über 100 abgeordnete des
ukrainischen parlaments zu den waffen
gegriffen
das gelbe klebeband am arm zeigt dass
hier keine ausgebildeten soldaten
kämpfen und der front sollen sie dadurch
für die eigenen leute erkennbar sein
einige dieser männer haben die zuvor
eine waffe in der hand gehalten
mit ihrer erfahrung aber es melden sich
genauso männer die leihe stifte oder
klaviertasten gegen waffen tauschen das
sind ganz normale ukraine die gegen das
unrecht kämpfen wenn das hier vorbei ist
schreibe ich ein buch über die
geschichte dieses krieges
auf dem bahnhof von lwiw im westen der
ukraine chaotische zustände
sicherheitskräfte haben den zugang zum
bahnsteig gesperrt glück hat wer es in
einen der wenigen zu geschafft
es ist eine traurige reise wir kommen
aus dem osten der ukraine
gerade ist es mehr oder weniger ruhig
aber früher oder später könnte alles
kommen also werde ich und meine kinder
und meine mutter zuerst nach polen
reisen ich weiß nicht welchen weg wir
jetzt versuchen werden weil es wirklich
schwierig ist und dann gehen wir nach
deutschland
auf diesem bahnsteig müssen auch viele
familien voneinander abschied nehmen
denn für die männer zwischen 18 und 60
ist die ausreise verboten
wir möchten mit dem zug nach polen
offenbar kann ich nicht mit über die
grenze denn ich bin ein fan also
begleite ich meine frau und meine kinder
zum zug
in der zweitgrößten stadt der ukraine
aktiv kam es heute offenbar erneut zu
heftigen kämpfen schon am sonntag sollen
russische truppen in die stadt
eingedrungen aber laut dem ukrainischen
innenminister wieder zurückgeworfen
worden sein die heutigen kämpfe um die
stadt zwingen wieder viele einwohner in
schutzräume
wir sitzen in einem bunker in kharkiv
hier gibt es viele sabotage gruppen
die gehen durch die stadt und versuchen
zu töten und sprengsätze zu verteilen
deshalb haben die streitkräfte und
befohlen in den bunkern zu bleiben und
nicht rauszukommen ein sehr schwieriger
tag
im laufe des tages ein neuer luftalarm
auch hier in kiew
die menschen in der ukraine müssen
vielerorts weiter um ihr leben bangen
in washington am weißen haus ist unser
korrespondent elmar theveßen
zugeschaltet guten abend elmer
vor wenigen minuten in deutschland ja
vor wenigen minuten das war jedenfalls
der plan wollte us präsident biden vor
die presse treten zu einem anderen thema
aber hat er sich möglicherweise auch zu
russland ukraine geäußert
nein das hat er noch nicht getan wir
gehen davon aus dass er später am tag
sich noch äußern wird er hat sich ja
heute im laufe des morgens unserer zeit
zu einer telefon konferenz getroffen mit
den spitzen der g7 der eu und auch der
nato um vor allen dingen glauben wir
zwei dinge zu beraten das eine ist was
passiert in den nächsten tagen wenn
tatsächlich putin sich entscheiden
sollte die lage in der ukraine noch
einmal massiv zu eskalieren das würde
bedeuten also zivile ziele ganz gezielt
anzugreifen sowie das offenbar in der
vergangenen nacht ja auch schon
attraktiv im osten des landes geschehen
ist wie wird man dann darauf reagieren
und wie kann man sicherstellen dass wenn
kiew eingekesselt würde man weiterhin
auch waffen und munition noch an die
ukraine liefern könnte und das zweite
natürlich die große frage wie reagiert
man darauf dass russland seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt hat da hat man bewusst am
wochenende geschwiegen und man wollte
sich erst einmal mit den verbündeten
dazu abstimmen ja das wäre jetzt mal
nachfrage gewesen wie ernst nimmt man
dann diese drohungen mit atomwaffen
das nimmt man sehr ernst zwar gehört zur
russischen militärdoktrin immer dazu in
den letzten jahren dass man schon mal so
etwas sagen kann das ist tatsächlich
sogar aufgeschrieben schriftlich
nachzulesen aber man macht sich deshalb
sorgen weil putin mittlerweile als
unberechenbar geld man weiß nicht mehr
ob er tatsächlich und das wird hier
offen ausgesprochen den hintergrund
treffen ob er herr seiner sinne ist und
deswegen macht man sich große sorgen
aber man will eben nicht durch
irgendwelche überreaktionen hier in den
usa dann weiter eskalieren dass die
amerikaner jetzt machen das pentagon ist
beobachtet durch die
aufklärungsmöglichkeiten die man hat
speziell über satelliten technik was
genau passiert die strategischen
atomwaffen russland sind natürlich
jederzeit
wright und da kann man sehen ob
möglicherweise die zahl des personals
auf diesen stützpunkten erhöht wird und
die nicht strategischen atomwaffen
müssten erst noch die sprengköpfe auf
diese raketen draufgesetzt werden auch
das sind aktivitäten die man entdecken
könnte und daraus darauf schaut man eben
ganz gezielt und wenn es eine
bestätigung dafür gibt was putin
angekündigt hat dass das wirklich
passiert dann öffentlich zu reagieren ob
man dann auch die atomstreitkräfte in
bereitschaft versetzt das ist ein großes
fragezeichen
einmal gibt es denn in washington pläne
russland auch wirtschaftlich noch härter
zu bestrafen als bisher beschlossen
ja im grunde genommen die härteste
sanktion wurde heute morgen bei einem
hintergrundgespräch uns beschrieben das
ist jetzt erst mal dass man auch gegen
die russische zentralbank vorgeht wir
haben die auswirkungen ja vorhin schon
in einem anderen gespräch gehört man
sagt hier man will das märchen von der
festung russland entlaufen also klar zu
machen dass russland und wladimir putin
auch keinen sparstrumpf mehr haben
gewissermaßen diese kriegskasse die
notwendig ist um diesen krieg
fortzusetzen aufzufüllen aus diesen
devisen die in anderen ländern lagern
dieser hahn ist auch zugedreht und man
will eventuell noch mal nachlegen man
hat bisher tatsächlich die
energieindustrie russlands ein stückweit
ausgespart das wäre die letzte große
sanktion die noch kommen könnte das
heißt tatsächlich kein gas kein öl
nichts mehr abnehmen und darüber haben
die g7 die nato und auch die eu vorhin
gesprochen in der telefonkonferenz
wie kann man sicherstellen dass die
europäischen märkte davon nicht zu stark
betroffen sind vielen dank nach
washington
wie verändert der krieg in der ukraine
die stimmung in russland selbst wie
reagieren die menschen auf die
verhängten wirtschaftlichen
strafmaßnahmen die kollegen in moskau
haben sich auf den straßen umgehört wir
zeigen ihnen einige stimmen
stoppen sie unsere politiker in
irgendeiner weise verstehen sie denn
irgendwer muss die es doch tun
wissen sie dies passiert nicht das erste
mal in meinem kurzen leben hat es sowohl
den zusammenbruch der sowjetunion als
auch alles mögliche gegeben daher das
macht nichts wir überleben das
bei mir sind die finanzen in ordnung ich
mache mir wegen dieser situation keine
sorge fragen sie mich nicht jeder
überlebt wie er kann
wir werden wahrscheinlich dazu kommen
dass es eine revolution geben wird die
geduld wird enden früher oder später
wird dem russischen volk der
geduldsfaden reißen das kann ich ihnen
garantieren
ich bin auf mein land und mein
präsidenten stolz pumpt
und in moskau ist unser korrespondent
christian selben guten abend schön
abend die menschen machen sich ganz
offenbar auch sorgen dass ihnen das
bargeld ausgehen könnte
hallo christian ich habs jetzt leider
ich habe es jetzt leider nicht
verstanden ich habe nun endlich zeit
verstanden ja dass die menschen sich
sorgen und thema geld
[Musik]
genau zum thema bargeld kann ich ihnen
sagen dass wir das hier jetzt mehrfach
in moskau gesehen haben dass es an den
geldautomaten schlangen gibt das ist
jetzt nicht flecken flächendeckend in
der ganzen stadt muss man sich das nicht
vorstellen aber eben vereinzelt weil die
menschen sich sorgen machen und
versuchen bargeld zu kriegen und das
klappt dann auch nicht überall ich habe
das jetzt auch versucht mit meiner
deutschen kreditkarte an einem automaten
habe ich gar nichts bekommen an dem
anderen automaten nicht so viel wie man
dort sonst bekommt und ich habe den
eindruck dass jetzt immer mehr im alltag
der menschen auch dieser krieg ankommt
wir haben ja schon viel die letzten tage
über die staatliche propaganda geredet
wie menschen sich informieren jetzt
merken die menschen dass die
auswirkungen des krieges eben zb an den
geldautomaten und sich es macht sich so
ein bisschen mehr unruhe breit und die
menschen fragen sich natürlich auch wo
führt das hin auch wenn wir das thema
reisen betrachten die gestrichenen
flugverbindungen und möglichkeiten
überhaupt noch nach russland zu reisen
oder aus russland wegzukommen das macht
den menschen sorgen und ich hatte auch
das gespräch mit einem freund und habe
gefallen wie seht ihr das in der familie
und wie diskutiert ihr das und er sagt
wir machen uns alle große sorgen wir
machen uns große sorgen
putin die unsere zukunft jetzt sozusagen
zerstört hat zerstört hat und niemand
kann uns da im moment helfen die eu hat
harte sanktionen verhängt die usa und
kanada auch heute hat sich auch die
schweiz dem angeschlossen wie reagiert
eigentlich der kanne darauf
der kreml hat ja immer versucht auch im
vorfeld bevor die sanktionen beschlossen
wurden zu zeigen dass man damit
klarkommt dass man sie im griff haben
kann aber jetzt merke mir doch die
letzten tage dass die sanktionen so
massiv sind und so schnell sind dass man
das hier im kreml glaube ich auch nicht
erwartet hat das merkt man auch an putin
dessen rhetoriker immer schärfer
geworden ist hat heute zuletzt hatte den
westen als ein imperium der lügen
bezeichnet gestern die abschreckungs
kräfte in alarmbereitschaft gesetzt auch
als folge dieser sanktionen also man
merkt die sanktionen wirken und putin
hat damit wohl so nicht gerechnet vielen
dank für diese einschätzung nach moskau
es ist bis jetzt ein tag ohne
entscheidende wendung im kriegsgeschehen
russland so sehen es viele experten ist
deutlich langsamer vorangekommen mit
deutlich mehr verlusten als erwartet der
ukrainische widerstand ist ganz offenbar
ungebrochen
alle weiteren entwicklungen können sie
bei zdf heute.de und jetzt gleich bei
heute live verfolgen und dann im heute
journal um 21.45 und hier geht es jetzt
weiter mit dem fernsehfilm der woche auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben sie immer aktuell informiert im
zdf und der zdf- heute- app
wenn es